it looks like such a harmless little
thing and then when you touch it
aliens attack what this ball isn't from
outer space it's from Mexico this is
what biologists call creepy
zookeeper Pablo Rivera just couldn't
resist poking the giant ball but what in
the name of nature happened next
these are harvestman are commonly known
as daddy longlegs they are not spiders
although they are closely related
they're very ancient species so it's
thought that they were actually
inhabiting a supercontinent when all
continents are still together and that's
why we see them all across the world now
the reason the daddy longlegs have
combined to make this ball of fluff
which is called an aggregate is because
they like to spend their nights hunting
and their daytime clustered together in
small cold dark places the other
advantage of aggregates is defense but
if there is safety in numbers and why do
these long legs scatter after Pablo's
poke this is something we call the
dilution effect and it's actually quite
beneficial to prey species because
predators get very very confused for so
many individuals running around but
instead of confusing a predator all
they're doing is making a grown-man
screen